un rêve que j'ai
fait cette nuit-là m'est revenu
jonathan dante ramait seul sur un bateau les
seins de tara m'ont fait penser au
rêve
le bateau à côté duquel je nageais alors qu'il
chevauchait
le grand océan était calme et clair
et seuls mon père et moi étions  présent
de temps en temps je l'ai regardé
mais il ne m'a jamais reconnu
et il n'a jamais arrêté de ramer c'était un
rêve qui se répétait
je l'avais eu encore et encore pendant des années cela se
terminait généralement par lui ramant et
disparaissant
dans le bateau c'était le  première fois que j'ai fait
le rêve
depuis la mort de dante cette fois
j'étais seul dans l'eau dante était parti
que nous étions tous les deux dans le bateau à la fin
de sa vie
nous étions tous les deux tout
c'était incroyable que toute la merde entre
nous
ait été guérie là  il n'y avait que de
bons sentiments entre moi et mon père
à la fin
rien que de bons sentiments et c'est
merveilleux
parce que nous avions une relation tellement moche
quand j'étais enfant mais quand j'ai grandi,
je veux dire dans la virilité,
ça s'est beaucoup mieux
secoué le
scénario voici john fonte est décédé
à l'hôpital du cinéma à los
angeles le 8 mai
1983. il avait 74 ans
c'est merveilleux pour moi d'être ici parce que
euh potenza
est la ville de naissance de ma grand-mère
donc pour moi c'est un  pèlerinage
pendant 20 ans j'étais euh
un alcoolique et très
et de cela vient une sorte de
désespoir
dont vous mourez ou survivez
euh ce qu'il
ne savait pas c'est que je sais
désespéré aussi et fou
et quand le vide et la solitude et la
rage peuvent faire
quand vous n'avez rien d'autre que votre propre
douleur dans vos poches et que votre maison est une
pontiac de 1978 en panne bloquée dans une ruelle de l'ouest de Los Angeles
et que la voix dans votre esprit
vous découpe et
vous tue davantage
chaque jour et  vous vous réveillez et buvez plus de
vin de pisse de rat
pour vous protéger de la folie instantanée et dieu
devient un gars qui sort du 7-eleven
vous remettant de la monnaie vers une autre
[ __ ] de cruche et la peur est votre meilleur
sentiment
et l'amour est mort et tout le temps est mort
et même vos dents puent et votre intestin
est gonflé par les voix hurlantes
de ceux que vous détestez et la seule vraie
santé mentale qu'il y a peut être trouvée dans le
petit miracle de sucer
un verre de plus qui signifie que le chat blanc
ne savait pas que j'ai  été coupé aussi du
même tissu
la seule différence entre nous est de
10 ans et ma machine à écrire
mon nom est dan fonte je suis né et j'ai
grandi à los angeles californie je
suis un écrivain américain
génétiquement je viens d'une
tradition orale mon grand-père
était un conteur  dans un brutal
et mon grand-père traînait dans les bars
et racontait des histoires avec ses amis et il
racontait les histoires de mon père
et mon père j'entendais mon père
raconter des histoires
et donc c'est vraiment mon père a été le
premier à
commettre la tradition orale à  sur papier
mais alors que nous sommes en tant que conteurs
nous trois
juste des conteurs
c'est aujourd'hui c'était il y a
100 ans la
ville de mon grand-père en italie
ce sont les gens les plus gentils du monde
ils sont
comme ma famille tu sais
voyons la photo de mon
mon  le 80e anniversaire de la mère
donc il y a neuf ans mon frère qui est mort
mon petit frère ma la
femme de mon frère aîné
moi-même ma sœur ma
mère
ma première petite-fille
c'est elle est malade je suppose qu'il y a sept ans
hein c'est
un bébé elle a été baptisée
mon fils et euh
sa femme je  garder des images derrière des images
ah qui est ce rene ferreira
pour une raison quelconque comme je l'ai dit
je garde des images derrière des images donc
c'est très intéressant ce que nous trouverons
cela pourrait être une aventure
voyons voir mais je veux trouver cette
photo
de mon ex-femme voyons voir
euh ce n'est pas mon ex-femme
elle a l'air ils ont l'air très proches ils sont
comme des jumeaux
je vais vous montrer à la librairie
ils ont mis mon nom sur le chapiteau du
cinéma tu vois
j'ai fait une lecture avec un de mes amis alors
tu vois le studio
hein et c'est la star de cinéma juste
là
sympa j'aime
bien ok
je vais trouver cette photo de ma ah
là elle est de
la merde
donc je l'ai
bien trouvé c'est pas une bonne photo je pense et
j'étais plus lourd aussi
bien  c'est une bonne photo d'elle elle était
mignonne
d'accord ça n'a pas marché
je vais réessayer c'est
comme une chirurgie c'est comme une chirurgie du cerveau
ce ne sera pas comme neuf mais ce
sera fonctionnel
voila
mon père a eu une énorme influence sur
moi pas
lui mais son écriture ses mots sur papier
étaient un modèle d'excellence
et bukowski était une influence aussi et je
lisais bukowski à l'époque et
sa poésie était quelque chose de libérateur pour
moi
je me suis donné la permission et donc j'ai commencé
à écrire
et et sortir  à partir de là, il a commencé à y avoir un
thème
cohérent et j'ai poursuivi ce
en un an, j'avais peut-être 250 pages,
ils n'étaient pas très bons mais ils faisaient 250
pages
et à partir de cela,
j'ai travaillé très dur
pour obtenir  mon style en bas de mon style
est
si
si des écrivains comme john updike et john
grisham
sont cappuccino mon
style est expresso
et la différence est que
je ne veux pas de violons et je ne
veux pas d'
oiseaux qui volent et je ne veux pas de
musique euh  comédie en arrière-plan
je garde mon objectif est de garder
chaque phrase courte et d'
avoir du punch euh euh
je suis un j'écris de la
fiction j'écris euh
j'écris ce que j'espère être
une représentation honnête de l'émotion les
émotions sont ce qui est important pour  moi
les émotions sont honnêtes à cent pour cent
la folie est honnête à cent pour cent
le euh euh bukowski s'il a dit que c'était
sa vérité à 90 pour cent euh euh je ne le crois pas
je ne le crois pas euh parce que euh
ou ou si tu  Je suis esclave de
euh enregistrer des événements alors c'est
biographique
euh et euh euh alors ce n'est pas
que ce n'est plus un roman c'est par sa
biographie
euh je le fais ça ne marche pas pour moi
donc il y a un pourcentage élevé
de ce qui est arrivé à  moi
dans les livres mais euh
non je ce serait euh ce serait
malhonnête de ma part de dire que
j'essaie de trouver cette [ __ ]
de librairie et euh je
pense que je l'ai perdu maintenant laissez moi voir
pas de parking de 8h à 10h  ça veut dire
que ça va
pas de parking à tout moment
sauf deux heures de stationnement de
8h00 à 18h00 du lundi au vendredi je
n'ai aucune idée je pense que ça va je pense que ça
va
jesus dieu
essayant de s'en souvenir john fonte m'a encore rendu visite
ce matin il est venu
à moi derrière mes yeux
et
il se tenait derrière ma chaise
et je l'ai senti et je me suis
retourné j'ai fermé les yeux
et j'ai senti sa présence
et j'ai dit
euh ce fantôme
ne se souvient pas du [ __ ] de poème je ne me
souviens pas du [ __ ] de poème
d'accord euh je dois le faire pour toi dans
la voiture
comment tu vas
oh très bien très
bien
jésus d'accord
on y va
donc tu aurais un vrai pistolet est-
ce que tu l'as
eu il y a
dix ans et ils ne l'ont pas fait
avoir des titres de john fonte
euh et donc euh
maintenant ils ont dix
titres de john fonte et euh donc je suis allé dans le je
me souviens d'y être allé pour la première
fois et d'avoir parlé au propriétaire
et euh et d'avoir dit euh tu sais que mon père était
un
j'avais l'habitude de  j'avais l'habitude de pimper la littérature de mon père
euh quand j'ai commencé à écrire
et la raison pour laquelle je l'ai fait était parce qu'il
était un
écrivain local et que je voulais que les gens lisent
ses trucs
et donc je suis allé là-bas euh c'est l'une
des librairies où je suis allé  dans
et j'ai demandé euh les
gars, s'il vous plaît, emportez John Fonte
parce qu'il est un écrivain
et qu'ils n'avaient pas entendu parler de lui à ce
moment-là
et la bonne nouvelle est que
nous sommes en 2002 et
qu'ils ont environ 10 des titres de mon vieil homme
maintenant maintenant nous devons  demandez-leur d'obtenir plus
de mes tuiles,
ils ont un de mes livres là-dedans et
euh
et j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils le fassent
s'ils transportaient plus de mes affaires
éteignez la lumière
vous n'avez pas le droit
à travers les mots
soulevez vos paupières plombées
je vais essayer de me souvenir de
ce matin
john fonte est venu vers moi ce matin
il était debout derrière moi
pendant que j'écrivais
son souffle chaud
j'ai senti son souffle chaud
sur mon cou
et quand j'ai fermé les yeux
je pouvais le voir
à  sa table d'écriture
à malibu
tapant les mots de tommy gunn
sur sa vieille machine à écrire
et j'ai ressenti une
douleur ancienne mais familière
et je l'ai appelé
quand j'ai commencé à travailler dans des emplois de télémarketing
et le service de limousine euh
et j'ai commencé à écrire des livres ma mère
est devenue très  en colère contre moi
parce qu'elle pensait que je perdais mon
temps
elle trouvait que c'était un stupide
inutile mais elle ne voulait
plus d'écrivains dans la famille elle
n'aimait pas mes livres elle disait que c'était des
ordures parce qu'elle gérait
les livres de mon père  et euh toutes ses
affaires littéraires et
elle sentait que je pense qu'elle sentait
que mon écriture était
en quelque sorte une compétition tu sais en quelque sorte
euh je ne sais pas qu'elle
voulait me tenir à l'
écart de tout ça alors elle l'a fait
pendant de nombreuses années euh nous l'avons fait  ne se parle pas
assez ma mère maintenant
à ces jours-ci c'est différent
quand nous sommes absents
et je suis à la maison en train de
presser la journée
pour être pleinement
reconnu
avec moi
car tu es
tous les meubles et tous les livres et
tout euh mais
j'étais toujours  j'avais encore un souvenir de mon père
mais euh
mais maintenant qu'il n'y a plus de meubles dans
la maison
maintenant qu'euh c'est vacant c'est
euh je m'en souviens mais c'est pas pareil
tu sais c'est pas moi ça n'a pas
l'impression
de  mon père plus ou ma famille
ma mère a vécu dans la maison pendant 50
ans
mais pendant que mon père était vivant chaque année
il a essayé de vendre la maison chaque année
chaque année toujours le panneau était
à vendre
c'est très drôle
ma mère était suicidaire quand elle était
enceinte de moi
et mon père était dans un
endroit psychologiquement terrible, il buvait beaucoup
et mon père était sujet aux rages
et donc il faisait rage et
criait et et mon lui et ma mère
ne s'entendaient pas et il ne voulait pas venir
à l'hôpital quand je suis né
et cetera pour que euh c'est un
souvenir intéressant euh
euh une partie est un souvenir euh mais
certainement je sais que j'étais
très bouleversé quand j'étais enfant et euh
et j'ai failli mourir plusieurs fois au cours des
premiers mois de  ma vie
je ne pouvais pas garder de nourriture je ne pouvais pas conserver de
nourriture j'étais
je rejetais toute la nourriture qu'on
m'avait donnée une librairie si cosmopolite pour
1750.
c'est parce qu'il n'y avait pas de jaquette le
10 octobre de
l'année prochaine
oh
oh merci  lis encore beaucoup
lis-tu encore
beaucoup combien de livres par semaine eh bien je ne sais
pas vraiment que fais-tu avec
tous tes livres eh bien
je fais des réservations non mais tu n'as pas d'
espace
souviens-toi que
oui tu te souviens du  garage dans euh
dans ta maison ouais il y a un il
n'y avait plus de place dans le garage
à cause de tous les livres que tu lis
et je me suis débarrassé de beaucoup d'insuline
je quand j'ai lu euh
changement idiot
je pense que peu de temps après j'ai
dîné avec dan  et
je vous savez que j'ai apprécié le livre mais
le passage qui me faisait vaguement référence
était quelque chose que vous savez que je ne pensais pas du
tout, euh, alors nous en avons parlé et
euh
dan a dit la même chose alors il dit
maintenant vous savez que
c'est c'est  fiction donc le personnage que
j'ai utilisé de vous,
il était comme un gars qui allait obtenir
un MBA et il n'avait jamais
eu l'esprit concentré sur
vous savez tout savoir et il
connaissait toutes les options d'achat d'actions et il savait ce
que
les gens devraient  faire et tout ce que
vous savez ce que
j'ai aimé à ce sujet ma
partie préférée en
fait dans le livre et l'écriture c'était
ma préférée était le
moment du trajet de
la maison à malibu à cedar sinai
et ils
euh il y a un il y a  une scène où
les voitures sont arrêtées et vous devez
tourner à gauche et là et
elles et enfin ce gars il pille
il n'a pas son temps donc il doit se
précipiter dans
la circulation et faire un virage vous savez
honnêtement d'accord
parce que c'est tout au début
vous écrivez parce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire non non
non parce qu'évidemment vous vous tenez là
aussi parce que vous voulez dire quelque chose
mais évidemment vous aimeriez que les gens
sortent et lisent votre livre donc vous voulez
le vendre pour que les gens et si vous '  Je suis là-haut en train de
parler,
alors peut-être que les gens s'intéresseront
à ce que vous dites et achèteront votre livre.
mon travail, je veux dire que
le premier livre commence pour ne pas le dire
grossièrement,
mais si je me souviens bien, le premier
paragraphe est que vous savez qu'il dit comme si
je n'étais pas gay mais j'étais dans un cinéma porno
et comme euh un mec m'a sucé tu
sais  et ou
quelque chose comme ça c'était [ __ ] de
quelque chose et euh tu sais que c'est un bon
début pour un livre de quelqu'un qui est
très en conflit et pour moi ce genre de
capture
tu sais ce moment en Amérique j'écris un
récit à la première personne
et c'est ça le problème le
problème  c'est que les éditeurs ne veulent pas
publier de récit à la première personne
assez intéressant les français et les
italiens
euh et les allemands aiment le récit à la première personne
vous savez mais l'autre
d'un autre côté les mémoires sont chauds
vous savez et donc c'est comme vos
livres  sont en quelque sorte romanesques mais à la
première personne, c'est que ce que vous dites
ouais mais le récit à la première personne a été
que c'était le
problème de mon père c'est la
fois de Los Angeles avez-vous vu cet article ouais
d'accord et puis euh il
y a deux semaines
le best-seller du los angeles times  lister la
section fiction mon père était le numéro 15
la semaine avant qu'il ne soit le numéro
13. mais le plus drôle est comme dans je
pense que c'est je ne sais pas si ça a été un
changement de bêtise
mais vous savez où le
personnage fictif de votre père apparaît  ce qui est
drôle, c'est que
vous faites toujours tout votre possible pour
lui rendre hommage et
au moins vous savez en tant que lecteur qui, comme je
n'ai pas d'
intérêt pour les questions familiales, vous savez juste
lire le livre en tant que lecteur
le premier  temps avant que je te connaisse vraiment du
tout
euh j'étais comme un dieu étonné que ce gars soit si
respectueux envers son père
et il a en fait pris son père dans son
livre
et en quelque sorte écrire un tu sais
pour lui écrire une lettre tu sais ou
te dire  sais à quel point je te respecte
et comme il a fait tout son possible comme lui tu
sais qu'il n'avait pas à faire ça et
c'est assez drôle alors
d'entendre plus tard comme eh bien il est tu connais
la chose la plus chère à papa
ou quelque chose comme ça et et
il n'y a rien de mal à cela je veux dire
si qui que soit votre père
si cela fait partie de votre histoire que vous
voulez lui rendre hommage
dans votre écriture vous savez qui s'en fout
qu'il soit célèbre ou
vous ne savez pas ou presque
ouais je sais comme avec  la plupart des familles eh
bien ouais mais alors tu as mon enfant
qui l'a moi qui l'a eu papa qui l'avait le
père de papa qui l'avait et le
père du père de papa
un matin je me suis réveillé et il m'est venu à l'esprit
que lors des funérailles
de mon frère personne n'a mentionné
ça  il avait la même maladie que moi qu'il
était alcoolique qu'il était
alcoolique
une ou deux fois dans ma vie est-ce que je me
souviens avoir vu papa
boire je veux dire qu'il avait un verre de vin
au dîner
mais je n'ai pas bu et
mais nous l'avons fait mais combien de fois l'avons-nous vu se
saouler très
jamais pas très souvent peut-être deux fois dans ma
vie
alors tu sais que c'est un tel
contraste avec l'endroit où il était euh
des années plus tôt avec toi et nick
alors nous avons grandi  un tout autre euh dans un
tout autre environnement
oh ouais que dan et nick oui
je savais que nick buvait encore rien qu'en le
voyant mais je n'avais
absolument aucune idée de quoi faire à ce sujet eh
bien tu ne peux rien y faire
mais tu sais s'il  appelé et dit tu
sais ce qu'il en est je suis je suis
ici à auburn et je me soûle
à mort
ils
ne font pas d'annonce
il voit juste que c'est mon point de vue le
point est
dans une famille avec un ivrogne comme ça
quelqu'un qui meurt d'alcoolisme
il y a un code de silence où
tout le monde où la femme
soutient le code de silence dont personne ne
parle
ce cadavre en décomposition dans le
salon
ce qu'ils font, c'est qu'ils trouvent des excuses
à ce sujet,
ils disent bien qu'il a démissionné ou mais la femme
qui était sa secrétaire a dit après avoir reçu
cette transfusion l'année précédente et
perdu tout ce sang
qu'il avait trois  des semaines hors de l'hôpital,
il buvait un litre par jour
et personne, je veux dire, sharon ne l'ignorerait, elle l'a
juste ignoré
et il vous le savez tellement l'a ignoré dans le
sens où
elle savait que cela se passait mais elle n'a
dit à personne
qu'il l'a fait  Je ne le dis à personne donc il y a et
et
au monde extérieur ils ont protégé le
secret
une fois
la première fois que j'ai eu une
expérience spirituelle c'était quand je me suis saoulé quand j'avais
cinq ans
et euh et je me souviens que c'est
fascinant
parce que ma mère était avec un artiste un
sculpteur
et ils buvaient de la bière à midi
dans son salon à los angeles et
ils la buvaient dans des chopes en étain
avec de longues poignées en étain et
ils ont quitté la pièce et j'ai bu
leurs deux bières
et je me souviens m'être levé et me
cogner la tête sur le  bas du
piano
donc j'avais quatre ou cinq ans à l'époque et c'était
la première
fois que je me sentais libre
euh il a 20 ans de moins que moi
nous avons 20 ans et
une semaine d'écart
donc j'étais un petit garçon quand il est né
il avait  supporter beaucoup de conneries de
ma part
la vie a été difficile pour lui
j'ai vécu à new york quand il était petit
mon père l'emmenait à
des matchs de baseball
et au cinéma et vous savez ces choses auxquelles
ce poème est destiné  mon fils jeffrey marche
avec seulement des mots et des livres
pendant que ton ami rêve les rêves d'
écrivains morts déviants saints qui venant avant
toi
ont noyé la douleur de leurs cœurs les plus purs
comme un chat mal aimé agité
jeffrey vicki es-tu là bonjour
bonjour bonjour
embrasser l'égoïsme et le chômage
fumer des millions  de cigarettes non filtrées
et te coller
désespérément le cul à la [ __ ] de crack ivre la plus diabolique
qui échange tes
couilles dans un instant new-yorkais contre le gars
au bout du bar avec un visage piqué
et un billet de cinquante dollars ne sois pas
courageux
souviens-toi que tous les hommes sont  imbéciles et
menteurs sans âme captifs de leur propre
état de sang nécessité et ne pardonnent
rien de
mon côté alors peut-être qu'un jour
comme moi vos pieds vous font mal et votre crâne
encore cru de la fête d'hier soir
vous renverserez une boîte ou tournerez une page
et vous retrouverez face à  visage
avec les yeux flous de Dieu
alors
j'étais avec mon ami et
une nuit où nous étions ivres
je travaillais dans
un parc d'attractions à Ocean Park
et nous avons décidé d'aller
à New York et
nous sommes donc restés debout toute la nuit
et nous avons commencé à faire de l'auto-stop  le premier
homme qui s'est arrêté nous a conduit 2 000
miles
et puis nous ne nous sommes pas arrêtés, nous avons changé
de conduite donc il n'y a pas eu d'arrêt
et nous avons dormi dans la voiture et euh
donc nous avons parcouru 2 000 miles en
je ne sais pas un jour et demi  ou deux
jours
et euh en très peu de temps
puis nous nous sommes retrouvés coincés ouais sous la pluie il
pleuvait
et puis nous avons eu deux autres trajets
et nous étions tout le chemin dans euh new
jersey qui est à côté de new york
donc nous avons eu trois trajets  au total, à
travers le pays, c'était
fantastique
et mais j'avais de nombreux emplois entre de
nombreux emplois.
film
encore et encore et encore et encore
donc je travaillais avec un gars
et nous buvions au travail
et nous avons fait un jeu nous connaissions
tous les dialogues des acteurs
et nous disions le dialogue juste
avant que les acteurs ne le disent
et les gens  étaient furieux
donc en gros ce que j'étais était un
chauffeur de taxi à new york un colporteur de rue
et
tant d'autres choses un huissier de cinéma aboyeur de
carnaval lave-
vaisselle
un assistant de
bureau un laveur de vitres un
préposé à la station-service euh
je ne peux même pas télévendeur
euh euh garde de sécurité
euh encore  non
les gars
ce n'est pas un monde généreux
après qu'il m'ait remis le livre le greffier est
parti par-dessus son épaule
il a appelé si vous le voulez c'est 29.95 seul livre
de poche dante original que j'ai jamais eu
très rare c'était sans prétention et léger
dans ma main quand j'ai ouvert  si la colonne vertébrale
craquait
les pages étaient dures et sèches c'était tout ce qui
restait de mon père
j'ai commencé à lire sur la fille mexicaine
et ses sandales et le jeune écrivain fauché
voulant l'impressionner pour qu'elle tombe amoureuse en
renversant le café sur
le dessus de la table  sur le nickel qu'il y avait laissé
page après page,
chaque ligne se lisait comme la scène d'un gros
cul latin
l'honnêteté était aussi douloureuse que je
me souvenais que le
cœur fort et exposé de mon père était
partout
ce roman était le chef-d'œuvre de dante
écrit avant que les gros
chèques de paie de scénarisation d'hollywood
aient  l'a transformé en golfeur et en une vieille merde
amère,
je voulais crier
de partager cela pour m'assurer qu'une autre
personne vivante
connaîtrait cet écrivain qui a façonné l'
expérience sur ces pages
la grandeur de ce travail si ses livres
étaient lus je le ferais  faire quelque chose
pour mon père
eh bien je pense que la meilleure définition de
l'écrivain américain
d'un écrivain américain
il y a un
je pense qu'une tradition commence avec les
écrivains beat
pas de début euh
avant ça commence avec sherwood
anderson
à winesburg ohio et et
et nathaniel west et
dave le criquet
demandé la poussière par john fonte il y
a une tradition de cavaliers western une
sorte de tradition de
découverte de soi et puis
à travers les beats à travers kerouac
qui bien sûr n'était pas un écrivain western
mais
euh il y a une sorte de
nouvelle expérience oh et je dois pas '  il ne
faut certainement pas oublier steinbeck euh
je vis mon rêve je
suis mon rêve mon rêve était d'être écrivain
euh et pour rester en vie
je fais les deux c'est
la route de los angeles
au loin
peut être à un demi mile
de là  la route s'étend sur 200 miles
jusqu'à los angeles nous sommes à mi-chemin entre
las vegas et los angeles
c'est la colline ou une colline comme celle-ci
où arturo bandini a
marché jusqu'au sommet et a jeté une copie
de son livre dans le désert
vous le voyez où camila lopez a
marché avec  son chien
dans ce désert
incroyable hein donc
euh pour moi
le désert est la source d'inspiration
est la source euh
d'une relation entre moi et qui je
suis spirituellement
je pense que je ne peux parler que de moi
l'obligation que je ressens en tant qu'écrivain
est  explorer mon expérience
et raconter cela de telle manière qu'elle
ait
un impact sur lequel les
gens peuvent s'identifier et
cela peut élargir leur perception
de qui ils sont en lisant mon travail,
j'espère qu'ils se verront
dedans, puis en tant qu'écrivain  j'ai fait mon
travail, vous
ne savez pas plus que le reste, c'est des
conneries, le reste à propos de la philosophie
et de
l'intellectualité et de tous ces trucs
dont les écrivains parlent, en particulier les
écrivains américains,
c'est juste un non-sens tout ce que c'est est
mon expérience tout  c'est un cadeau de
donner
quelque chose en retour euh de tendre la main pour
prendre contact pour être
tactile pour dire voici quelque chose pour vous
alors alors
ah sautez changez les galères
c'est loin alors
que d'
accord maintenant vous êtes prêt
ouais d'accord d'accord je vais  vous montrer
cette boîte rouge qui était dans son garage
avec deux ou trois cents feuilles de
papier
dedans le premier brouillon
non c'est le deuxième brouillon c'est
le premier brouillon
de changement d'idiot euh
oh regarde regarde regarde ici le
j'ai commencé 1 9
91 c'est  la date à laquelle j'ai commencé
et terminé le 8 6 91 donc c'était sept
mois
et euh mais ce n'est que le premier brouillon
le
euh changement d'idiot m'a pris trois ans pour
écrire que quand j'écrivais le
changement d'idiot je n'avais pas
décidé
d'écrire  un livre j'ai décidé d'écrire
quelque chose sur une machine à écrire et peut-être une
histoire courte ou quelque chose comme ça
et ce qui s'est passé pour moi, c'est que
je suis allé dans le garage
de la maison de mon père à malibu
et dans une vieille boîte que
je viens de commencer pendant un après-midi j'étais
en passant par des boîtes
et j'ai trouvé une rame qui est de 500 feuilles
de ce papier en fait j'ai trouvé une demi-
rame d'environ 200 feuilles
et c'est du papier à dactylographie légal
mon père a écrit son dernier
roman fraternité du raisin
sur le même papier euh
en 1977
et je  utilisé le papier pour écrire la première
ébauche
de mon roman
maintenant voyons ce que nous avons d'autre ici
vous avez fait un homme seul
je ne supporte pas
de regarder votre visage
et quand vous bougez votre jambe
avec grâce